when the situation seems dire and the
music swells that's when a superhero
shows up to save the day
of course not all superhero entrances
are created equal
from the man of steel to earth's
mightiest heroes here are the most epic
superhero entrances in movies the
promotion for superman the movie
promised that would believe a man can
fly
it was a bold claim and won the movie
had to back up richard donner and
company weren't going for childish glee
like all previous live-action superman
incarnations they truly wanted you to
believe and
every frame was directed toward that end
john williams swashbuckling score over
the spacey credits kicked things off
masterfully
casting christopher reeve was critical
equally critical with the special
effects
if we saw just one wire carrying the man
of steel like a marionette it would all
be ruined
thankfully none of that happened it's an
epic moment when a much younger clark
kent played by jeff east
arrives at his fortress of solitude to
take on the mantle of khalil the last
son of krypton
your name is carl you are the only
survivor of the planet krypton
q williams orchestral march the superman
is transformed into a man
and christopher reeve flies in costume
and into legend ready to deliver
a five finger patriotic punch of truth
justice and the american way
after superman the movie ruled the box
office in 1978
a sequel was a foregone conclusion
actually it was happening regardless of
the money because both
movies were filmed at the same time
despite a lot of behind the scenes drama
with directors
superman 2 eventually took flight and
the plot finds our fair planet in peril
as three kryptonians escape their
floating mirror prison
and seek vengeance on the son of the man
who put them there this trio of space
meanies imprisons humanity
eventually forcing the president of the
united states to kneel before zod
meanwhile superman has given up his
powers so he can be with his love lois
lane which seems remarkably
short-sighted given the circumstances
all hope seems lost when the three
kryptonians take lois hostage hoping to
lure the man of tomorrow out for a round
of fisticuffs
but as they say be careful what you wish
for general
would you care to step outside superman
superman thank god it's a bird it's a
plane nope it's the red and blue boy
scouts coming to kick zod's butt
tim burton is mostly known for his
incredible eccentric style
but the guy clearly has sharp box office
sensibilities
take batman for instance the movie's
success is directly attributable to this
one fact
fanboys dug it and they were especially
crazy about batman's entrances the film
features two iconic entrances which fans
are still quoting
30 years later batman's first appearance
comes in the beginning of the film
and features michael keaton taking out
two hoodlums who have just mugged a
family
i'd like you to do me a favor i want you
to tell all your friends about me
what are you i'm batman
it was such an effective line that
filmmakers are still copying it today
arguably even more awesome as batman's
entrance later in the flick
after jack nicholson's joker kidnapped
innocent reporter vicky vale
the caged crusader burst through the
glass ceiling with perfect timing
after all timing is everything in show
business and super heroics
remember what we said about filmmakers
copying the i'm batman moment
well that line was so memorable it was
repeated 16 years later
in the warner brothers reboot batman
begins you know your scene is special
when even uber original director
christopher nolan feels the need to
borrow it
the setup however is much different this
isn't our first encounter with bruce
wayne by this point
we've been with wayne on his journey
from disenchanted youth to prison body
to ninja warrior
and after an hour of build up we see him
for the first time as a man in black
vicious mob boss carmine falcone is
making a deal on the ducks
like he's safely done a million times
before but this is batman's towel now
with the pacing of a horror movie a
shadowy figure takes out the hoods one
by one
falcone attempts to escape in his limo
when batman arrives
what the hell are you
i'm batman hey just because a moment as
an homage doesn't make it any less epic
batman just seems to naturally lend
himself to awesome entries and for proof
look no further than the dark knight
rises the final entry in christopher
nolan's dark knight trilogy
may not have quite lived up to its
sky-high expectations but it wasn't for
a lack of awesome entrances
the first sees batman returning after
eight years as the league of shadows has
just invaded gotham's equivalent of wall
street
as night falls on the city the police
are in hot pursuit of the villains
suddenly several overhead lights go out
boy you are in for a show tonight son
as han zimmer's score reaches its
crescendo we realize the old timer is
right
batman is back but then he gets his back
broken by bane
winds up imprisoned underground in an
undisclosed location
and watches helplessly as gotham city is
held hostage by terrorists
boy that sucks however you can't keep a
good bat down and the caped crusader
rises from his subterranean prison
and returns home of course he can't just
sneak up on the unsuspecting vein
no that would be too simple he has to
make a statement so he sets a bridge on
fire with the symbol
maybe it's not practical but who cares
it's totally awesome
superman returns was not a great movie
it was so average in fact that warner
brothers abandoned this 200 million
franchise restart only returning to the
character after another seven year
hiatus all this aside one iconic scene
is unforgettable
superman has been gone for five years
lois lane is on a commercial jet being
carried by a nasa space shuttle
and the villainous lex luthor has just
set off a global electromagnetic shock
and of course that's when you know who
returns to earth through the windows of
the jet we see something red and blue
streak by
faster than a speeding bullet as the
opening strings of john williams score
teased superman's arrival long story
short superman saves the day
well i hope this experience hasn't put
any of you off flying
statistically speaking it's still the
safest way to travel
nothing fancy but bear in mind this was
the first time we got to see a live
action superman with modern cgi special
effects
the scene was the highlight of the film
proving that even a mediocre movie can
have an
epic entrance the avengers has more than
its share of epic entrances
there's iron man rescuing cap from loki
and thor riding a wave of lightning
bolts to capture his imprisoned brother
just for starters
but the most memorable of the bunch
comes in the film's final act
during the battle of new york a giant
evil space slug is attacking new york
city
mild-mannered bruce banner arrives on a
scooter ready to take it out
now might be a really good time for you
to get angry that's my secret cat
i'm always angry this moment is actually
two entrances for the price of one as it
immediately leads into the now classic
avengers wrap around scene
originally they were six individuals now
they're a team
avengers assemble while there have been
many attempts to bring wonder woman to
the big screen
the amazonian warrior princess hadn't
been seen in live action since linda
carter
however that change in the most unlikely
of places the first on-screen pairing of
batman and superman
despite the disappointment that followed
in its wake it's hard to overstate just
how monumental batman v superman dawn of
justice
was for fanboy culture this was the
first time batman and superman would
share the screen in a live-action film
plus wonder woman was going to show up
too it should have been great
it was not however wonder woman's
entrance was a dream come true for
millions of fans worldwide
while diana prince had been a principal
character in the film she didn't appear
in the red blue and gold until the final
battle
doomsday is about to blast batman into
oblivion when with her now iconic led
zeppelin-like theme wailing in the
background
wonder woman appears to save the day if
your movie is only going to have one
good moment
make it a great one spider-man is
marvel's most famous character
and one of the most popular heroes in
comic book history by the time captain
america civil war arrived in 2016
the character had been on the screen
five times breaking several box office
records along the way
even after the dreadful amazing
spider-man films fans worldwide wanted
to see their favorite friendly
neighborhood superhero
in the marvel cinematic universe and
sure spider-man's entry in the mcu
wasn't exactly heroic
there was little fanfare or saving of
innocence he simply swung into the
middle of a tense confrontation between
iron man and captain america
captain big fan spider-man yeah we'll
talk about it later
just hey everyone good job it wasn't
even really the
focus of the scene however that was the
point here was a fresh unexpected vision
of a character
we'd grown accustomed to marvel's
franchise star was taking a backseat to
two characters
who only in the last 15 years have
become mainstream blockbuster stars in
their own right
it reflected the characters perfectly
here he was
a literal kid learning the ropes of how
to be a hero in other words this was the
essence of spider-man
directed by patty jenkins wonder woman
features an entrance unlike any other
taking place in the grisly bits of world
war 1 trench warfare
the setting is more reminiscent of band
of brothers than of a superhero movie
after witnessing the suffering of
innocent villagers and the madness of
world war 1 raging around her
wonder woman is moved to action she
bravely marches into no man's land
taking fire from countless german
soldiers upon arriving in the imprisoned
village of beld the amazonian warrior
princess pretty much single-handedly
wins the battle
like the demigod she is once again her
theme is the soundtrack and the
screaming electric guitar totally worked
in the 20th century setting
in an era dominated by mcu's effective
well-known storytelling style
and the dc eu's dark and dour films
there was something fresh and
invigorating about good old-fashioned
adventure storytelling
while the dc eu has had its ups and
downs wonder woman's entrance is
definitely a high point
in avengers infinity war chris hemsworth
makes a kind of entrance that inspires
actors to sign up for superhero movies
but of course poor thor has to go
through quite a lot before he shows up
to save the day
after getting smugged by thanos in the
first five minutes of the movie
and watching both his friend and brother
die along the way
the god of thunder is in a very bad
place thor wants revenge
but he needs a new weapon to take down
the mad titan so he travels to the
distant reaches of the galaxy
to have a battle axe made forged in the
heat from the heart of a star
meanwhile back on earth the battle of
wakanda is not going well for the
avengers
thanos's armies have breached the force
field and they're on the verge of
decimating the country
all hope seems lost when a beam of light
rains down from the heavens
thor's spinning axe stormbreaker takes
out the alien army like a fidget spinner
from hell
the avengers team players and thor is
back
[Music]
it's hilarious and awesome all at once
moments like this are why marvel is so
unstoppable
we all know that despite their best
efforts the avengers couldn't stop
thanos in infinity war the mad titan
snaps his fingers half the universe
turns to dust
and the avengers have to cook up a
complicated time heist to right the
wrongs of the past and as we come to the
end of avengers endgame's huge three
hour run time
that's when we get one of the most epic
entrances in all of cinema
while hulk successfully snaps the
infinity stones and brings everybody
back to life
thanos now has the upper hand in the
climactic battle his million monster
army has caught the avengers by surprise
and he seems poised to destroy what's
left of earth's mightiest heroes
reclaim the infinity stones and destroy
all life as we know it the heroes once
again find themselves in peril when
suddenly dr strange's familiar glowing
orange orb appears
king t'challa the black panther appears
the last we saw him he had been turned
into dust following thanos's snap
he's soon joined by doctor strange the
guardians of the galaxy
spider-man and the remainder of our once
fallen heroes
thanos's victory in infinity war has
been reversed
we're in the end game now the screen is
soon populated by thousands of wakandans
asgardians and other warriors ready to
wreak vengeance
upon thanos avengers
assemble only one word can describe such
an entrance
epic check out one of our newest videos
right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one